crowd-sourced Studios first off why did
you begin it was there like a catalyst
that something happened
sure yeah good question so um briefly I
had I think I had gotten turned down for
something I had written I don't remember
exactly the what the what the specific
catalyst wasn't on my end but something
made me start digging how many suspect
scripts are written every year and I had
always heard like there are like a
hundred thousand spec scripts written a
year I started thinking what happens to
those scripts you know that was sort of
the genesis of it and I did some
research and it's true there are at
least a hundred thousand spec scripts
written every single year which is an
enormous number and granted probably 90%
of them were garbage but there's still a
Shh a lot and last year 62 were optioned
or sold out of at least a hundred
thousand that's not an efficient system
to me I don't believe that there I
believe that there were I'm certain
there were scripts that will never see
the light of day that are just as worthy
of being produced being purchased
whatever it is I started thinking about
that what's a you know what's a better
way to or what's an alternative or
additional way to you know I put some
light on these scripts and what about
the guy or the girl who doesn't have a
rep and you know I have a manager so
like and to be a spec screenwriter now
and to be unwrapped you have to
basically send out a bunch of query
letters begging managers to read your
script like please will you read I'm 99
percent of the time you don't even get a
response much less enough a polite no so
I used to always be interested I would
wonder like is there another Bob Dylan
out there somewhere who's just you know
like the world will never know about him
because he or her or whatever because
he's just he's because of luck really
another story of prisoners you know that
movie with Hugh Jackman in
what's his name you know I movie with
Jake Gyllenhaal that's a great movies
you see it the way that that movie came
to be the writer Aaron I forget his last
name was working like in a mailroom
somewhere in Albany or whatever and and
he wrote a bunch of query letters to
managers literal letters not emails sent
out oh wow actual letter and one of them
found its way onto I think it was Adam
kohlbrenner at madhouse madhouse
entertainments desk and he just happened
to notice it the return the return I
think of the return I think maybe was
living in Brooklyn or something and
something about his last name were saw
the fact that he'd actually written a
letter sort of caught his attention so
he opened it and the guy said you know
I'm a screenwriter can I send you a
sample of some of my stuff or whatever
so kohlbrenner was like sure I think it
was cold I said sure send send me some
of your stuff so this kid Aaron sent him
I script I think it was one or two
scripts that he had written and
kohlbrenner said yeah you you've got
something but I don't really like these
scripts what else do you have so he you
know they ended up developing and it
took years and and thank God and I think
just think about the the sort of
coalescence of luck that happened that
that and now that wonderful movie came
to be just because he had a coal burner
happened to notice this thing and that's
that's terrible that it should take such
a stroke of luck for that should be a
better system in my view for scripts to
get through the gatekeepers or to the
gatekeepers and sort of get a fair shot
right so so I started thinking what's a
better way to do that and that's that's
kind of the short answer medium that's
the long answer to how we started it
you